el delegado encargado de estas
negociaciones del lado británico es el
enviado personal del primer ministro
este es un hecho bien especial se trata
decir simon gass quien es ha sido
embajador británico ante irán y ha sido
designado recientemente como el
encargado de temas de afganistán dentro
del gobierno del reino unido la idea es
como lo mencionas que se garantice que
el talibán garantice un corredor de
vuelos humanitarios para que los
británicos que no pudieron abandonar ese
país entre 100 a 150 y los afganos
elegibles porque trabajaron como
intérpretes de las tropas británicas o
incluso se ha hablado que integrantes
del ejército afgano que fue entrenado
por la otan y por las tropas británicas
entre 800 a 1.100 afganos puedan venir
al reino unido- sin correr ningún
peligro por supuesto no se conocen
mayores detalles de estas conversaciones
que avanzan en qatar un país que está
jugando un rol bien importante de ese
acercamiento del talibán a occidente
pero se ha hablado la posibilidad de que
el aeropuerto internacional de kabul a
ser manejado por un tercer país como
turquía pero como les digo no se conocen
todavía los detalles de estas
negociaciones de manera confidencial lo
cierto es que también hoy el diario el
telégrafo ha revelado que integrantes de
las centrales de inteligencia británica
se reunieron con mandos del talibán para
garantizar que desde ese país no se
efectuarán ese plan era un ataque
terrorista a occidente